I was going resumes prayer what about
this case right I know what you're
thinking but there's a life worth living
I promise I love you there we go
no no no no mom no oh I know what I want
to do yeah oh my god to space bob is
going to Spain look the sky is gone now
what the hell whoa that's kind of cool
ah watch where you go away ah [ __ ] your
car [ __ ]
I call this on skateboard over her car
nail leg please love me please I don't
have any friends [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] back I
haven't had sex in six days seven five
[ __ ] may only over car you [ __ ] you're
looking e you want to see a trick man
goddammit the railings are so [ __ ] I
swear to God
Oh nailed it
that's a real kinky [ __ ] I wish this
game was a porno I mean what I was just
born by status oh my god is my best
friend
hi man I missed ya you want to play some
where are you going
all right side you want it that way huh
come on be one with the railings they
said all right time to [ __ ] it up a
little bit more Bob where are you going
oh let's see you guys know started
without me
thank you
Bob what you actually thought they were
skating involved in this game come on
Bob don't be scared
let's go baby yeah there we go baby
I really gotta take a [ __ ] there's my
son back to infinity and beyond
brofist your face brofist take me home
skating three ow that's exactly what I
wanted to do to infinity and beyond
nothing
[Laughter]
nothing didn't do anything wasn't media
what's the bottle guy it's the bald guy
oh [ __ ] let me touch your balls plane
okay yes Bob just went full [ __ ] Bob
that's not how you smell your armpit I'm
pretty sure Bob what do you want to see
cool tricks just watch me do my Bob
thing
are you okay man die let me sit up in
your face I love you sorry Bob
hey man what a great day does anyone see
my pocket I'm Bob nailed it I got Bob
when will you stop being a [ __ ] idiot
skate the game that has absolutely
nothing to do with a title all right for
us
I hope you enjoyed watching I had a lot
of fun [ __ ] around and skate it's
such a dirty game I don't even know
anymore they were like if you one more
and let me know it's this guy a coma
birth today I see you breasts in the
next month sales
[Music]